okay my first guess is the activist who
raps as killer Mike of run the Jackass
whose latest album run the jewels for
was released for free digitally on
Wednesday Mike render from Atlanta
killer Mike how are you sir I'm so
appreciative of you for doing this I
know you had a busy week you made an
amazing speech there in your hometown
that everybody saw and I want to just
quote the one thing that you said over
and over in the speech and I'm glad you
emphasized it plot plan strategize
organize mobilize what all those things
have in common is it means we're
thinking about the future we're thinking
about tomorrow and I think when I look
at the politics of America you know
there's a great place for a protest and
being in the streets but Republicans are
better at voting and I think that was a
big part of your message that that's
what's really going to change stuff
organizing voting yeah well what we do
know about this republic is is the we
know that the bullet box in the ballot
box you know have both changes country
in a lot of ways and I think that the
ballot box is the most easily accessible
way on a local level especially to start
to change the fabric of this country I
think that the kids that were outraged
in the streets certainly deserve to be
outraged in the streets
I appreciate the protest I appreciate
destroying property when it's followed
the next day by real organizers I want
kids to know that the righteous anger is
certainly permitted and I would say
encouraged to waits inside you have to
say hey this is going on we had to do it
in 92 and after we did it we saw flooded
jobs programs coming to the community we
saw a gang truce happen and for a while
we saw a little peace and some of the
neighborhoods that had been destructed
and I think that coming out of this riot
season I think we're going to be looking
at more organizers and in terms of
voting the new Georgia project is going
on right now they're registering people
to vote as far south as I value Georgia
wood in the onion farms to right here in
some of the toughest neighborhoods in
Atlanta so I want to encourage people in
the local regional or state level
make sure they're supporting things like
the new Georgia so you're saying you are
supportive of some destruction of
property I know you're the son of a
policeman yourself yes yes and that
doesn't mean I want you to go out and
burn down everything tomorrow what that
means is property destroyed is insured
one of my businesses has a bullet hole
through the window I have insurance that
window who you replaced the young man
who died under the knee look lease
officer mr. Floyd his life will never be
replaced so I'm talking as a property
owner as a business owner the person who
owns apartment my property has been
destroyed before I've had to clean it up
I've had to do it with my own hands and
hire people so I understand that from a
property owner perspective but from a
young person's perspective they're so
full of Rage has been so suppressed that
is being currently oppressed in terms of
the duality of policing in this country
I can understand the destruction of
property but after the instructions
properly I need you to become an
organizer I need you to plot plan
strategize organize and mobilize so that
we can organize under legislation under
those Goldar legislation to make sure
that they equal rights with everyone I
was given in this country full
constitutional rights we enjoy power
so how long do you think the protests I
mean they seem to be dying down here in
LA we I think are not for the first time
today this is Thursday we're a day
earlier we tape now yeah then you'll see
it on Friday of having a curfew but you
know people don't have much to do now
they're there there was a lockdown
you have been cooped up they don't you
know a quarter of the country that was
working in February is not working now
so you have no job you know there's no
economy to come back to why not be in
the streets for a lot of people how long
do you think the protests could go on
should go on should it be an indefinite
movement
well Huey Huey Huey Newton said that
that's the will of people that the
people ultimately decide the atmosphere
and where the revolution goes my
challenge or my in camaraderie with the
people as we protest let's make sure we
plot plan strategize organize and
mobilize protesting is
first step it's when you come in the ICU
and you're bleeding they have to stop
the bleeding first and then how do we
stabilize location the stability comes
to leading up your local ballot boxes
it's in making sure that you building
your prostitute prosecutors races voting
in terms of who your mayors and Senators
are going to be you have to start there
and value isn't the only answer in my
community there must be a return to
supporting small and mid-level black
businesses because if I don't have an
economy of people that look like me
who's going to support my community
outside of the government if we learnt
that were ever going to be free of you
know total government control then we
can't people holding on government for
everything as well so I believe there's
legal goals we should have there's
legislative goals we should have those
educational goals that you have so I
don't believe protests ever ends as much
as it evolves into a way of life that
demands justice that even famous famous
to say until we all are free nobody
you